[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARJAI ROBERTS: Hi, my
name is Marjai Roberts,
welcome to Google.
I'm an advertising
strategist in SMB sales.
I'm here, honored and excited
to be hosting producer Will
Packer at Google here in
our Mountain View office.
We're here to talk
about his new comedy,
premiering on NBC,
called "Truth Be Told."
So I'll give some accolades
because you've got a lot here,
so I'll just run down
the list a little bit.
WILL PACKER: Give a lot,
don't give a little.
MARJAI ROBERTS: I'll
give a lot back.
WILL PACKER: Take your
time on the accolades part.
MARJAI ROBERTS: I'll
give a lot, cool--
WILL PACKER: Don't
sell me short.
MARJAI ROBERTS: I want
it all, I want it all.
Producer Will Packer
has established himself
as one of Hollywood's
box office hit makers
with several of his films
opening number one at the box
office, including "Stomp
the Yard," "Ride Along,"
"Think Like a Man," and
most recently my favorite,
"Straight Outta Compton."
He currently develops
his new projects
under his company, Will
Packer Productions.
He was a founder of the
Atlanta-based Rainforest Films
and is a co-founder of Bounce
TV, a broadcast network
geared towards
African-American households.
In 2014, he became one of the
only African-American producers
to have seven films
debut at number one
during opening weekend.
So that's no small
feat, of course.
WILL PACKER: Thank you.
MARJAI ROBERTS: I could go
on, but you guys probably
have seen a lot of Will
Packer produced films,
box office hits like "Takers,"
"This Christmas," "Obsessed,"
"No Good Deed," and
"The Wedding Ringer."
Will has continued to expand the
boundaries of what filmmakers
can achieve in creating a
viable space for content that
speaks to a diverse community.
So among Will's
many projects, Will
is here to talk to us about his
NBC comedy, "Truth Be Told,"
premiering October
16th, starring
Mark-Paul Gosselaar, Tone Bell,
Vanessa Lachey and Bresha Webb.
The new series is about two
diverse couples and best friend
neighbors living life.
They talk about all topics, not
off limits, from race to sex
to children and they
basically keep it real.
WILL PACKER: Not necessarily
all related together.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Oh
no, not together.
WILL PACKER: The order
you said it in felt weird.
But that's all
right, keep going.
MARJAI ROBERTS: No problem.
And basically they keep it
real on the subject matter
they cover so it's
a really cool show.
So with that, I wanted to
welcome Will Packer to Google
today.
WILL PACKER: Glad to
be here, absolutely.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
What's up?
MARJAI ROBERTS: Cool.
So welcome to Google.
I'm from Atlanta
too so I'm really
excited to be hosting you.
WILL PACKER: I love that.
We have Google in Atlanta
MARJAI ROBERTS: Nice.
Yes, Midtown.
WILL PACKER: How long have
you been here with Google?
MARJAI ROBERTS: I've
been here for about four
and a half years.
WILL PACKER: Yeah?
MARJAI ROBERTS: Yeah.
WILL PACKER: You like it?
MARJAI ROBERTS: I do.
WILL PACKER: Answer
correctly now,
I figure a lot of Google
people are watching.
MARJAI ROBERTS: It's
a great company--
WILL PACKER: There you go.
MARJAI ROBERTS: --it's awesome.
WILL PACKER: You're welcome.
I gave you that one,
that's called a layup.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Yeah.
Right.
Thank you.
Now, a group of
Googlers had a chance
to watch "Truth Be
Told" yesterday, we
really all liked it.
And wanted to start
off by asking,
can you tell us a little
bit about "Truth Be Told"
and where the title came from?
WILL PACKER: Yeah, absolutely.
So like you said,
it's a show on NBC,
it's a sitcom and
premieres October 16th
and it's about
these two couples.
And Mark-Paul Gosselaar
plays our character, Mitch,
and he's married to
a wonderful woman who
happens to be of Asian descent,
played by Vanessa Lachey.
His best friend is
played by Tone Bell, who
happens to be a black guy who's
married to a black woman named
Bresha Webb.
And I keep bringing up
the races of everybody
because it's kind of
organic to the show
the fact that it's diverse.
It's not one of these shows that
is diverse for diversity's sake
or because somebody
said, you know what?
We need, like,
somebody of color.
Let's put a black
dude in this role
or put an Asian
guy in that role.
It literally is based on the
creator, DJ Nash's, life.
And in his real life
his wife is Asian,
his best friend is
black, and oftentimes
in his core group of friends,
he's the only white dude.
He told me that
story and I loved it.
I was like, wait a minute.
You're the only white guy
in your friend circle?
I love that.
Welcome to my world, now
you see how it feels,
you're the minority.
And it gives him such an
interesting perspective
because in our show we
have this group of friends
and they all bring their
own preconceived notions,
and perceptions, and upbringings
to the various topics
that we discuss on the show,
and we see it all play out.
The title, "Truth Be Told,"
is really appropriate
because in real life when
you interact-- and of course,
this is Google,
so you guys know--
everybody now is connected.
And we're connected in ways
that we weren't 10 years ago.
And so you're
interacting with people
that are completely
outside your particular
demographic-- I don't care
if it's like people that
live around you, look
like you, worship
or believe in the
things you believe--
like you're talking to
everybody on any given
day through social media
and various networks.
So it means that when you
are on those social networks
oftentimes you're
brutally honest.
And when somebody says,
OK, truth be told,
you know you just
prepare yourself
because whatever
comes next is going
to brutally honest, is
not going to be filtered,
and that's how we
interact with real people.
And so that's an appropriate
title for our show
because this is a group of
four actual real friends
who organically
talk about things
in an unfiltered kind of way,
the way that real people do.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Yeah,
I definitely like that.
So what shaped your interest
in doing a TV project?
I know you started a lot in
film, what attracted you to TV?
WILL PACKER: I love
TV because it's
a different connection
with audiences
that you're able to foster.
So with the feature film-- even
the greatest feature film--
you go in and it's
an hour and a half,
two hour, two
hour-plus experience,
and for the most part,
it can stay with you
but when you leave
the theater, you've
left that film in the theater.
And until you do
another version of it,
you do a sequel
or you revisit it,
for the most part
that content is
meant to be encapsulated in
that period of time and be over.
Whereas with television,
you are intended
to invest in these characters
over the long term,
I really liked that.
As a creative filmmaker,
I liked the idea
of being a part of a process
that creates characters
that allows viewers to take the
journey over and over again.
So obviously the television
landscape is changing rapidly
now and the way people consume
television is changing,
but people still look for
that organic investment
with real characters,
people that they can really
get to know and really
get invested in.
MARJAI ROBERTS:
Agreed, definitely.
So in the first episode, you
cover a lot of subject matter.
You cover the "n"
word, you cover
unconscious bias,
choosing baby sitters
and making sure
they're not porn stars.
WILL PACKER: Yeah,
there's that, absolutely.
Always essential.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Exactly.
Can you give us a hint
about other topics
that will be covered
throughout the season?
WILL PACKER: Yeah--
the fun of the show
is that you take a really
close knit group of friends
who talk about things that real
friends talk about and don't
have to filter them.
So on the show, there's
things from when
do you talk to your
kids about religion.
On our show, you have one
couple that is devout Christian,
and the other couple
who is anything but.
And the daughter
comes back from school
and asks a question
about what is God?
And who is God?
And what does He
or She look like?
And the couples have fun with
their own perspectives on that.
There is a lot of talk
about things that--
like you talked about
unconscious bias?-- well,
there is an episode where our
character played by Tone Bell,
who's the black guy, thinks that
a restaurant owner is racist.
And he thinks that an
incident has happened
that was biased against
him because he was black,
that he comes out and he's so
mad about it, and it turns out,
the guy really wasn't racist.
But our white guy,
Mitch, is caught
in a, how do I tell my black
best friend that it wasn't
racist when he really, really
thinks it was, but he was wrong
and I don't want to
come off the wrong way?
So it's like, well, I think,
no, dammit, he's racist.
OK?
Now you gonna back me, right?
White guy, white guilt,
white privilege, right?
And what's the white guy
gonna say in that moment?
So it's fun to have those--
some awkward, some poignant,
but always provocative
and always real subjects.
MARJAI ROBERTS:
Definitely, definitely.
So you mentioned
there's a clear example
of unconscious bias
at the beginning,
in the pilot with the
valet, expressing something
related to unconscious bias.
And here at Google, we
do a lot of training
and it's a big initiative here
on training, and highlighting,
and recognizing unconscious
bias in the workplace.
So it sounds like--
WILL PACKER: And is there a lot
of unconscious bias at Google?
MARJAI ROBERTS: There's a lot
of unconscious bias everywhere,
I think--
WILL PACKER: That's
a good answer,
you're absolutely right.
Because--
MARJAI ROBERTS: --so
it's definitely something
that we really have to recognize
so that we can actually
change it.
WILL PACKER: And oftentimes,
by the very definition of it,
it's not intentional.
MARJAI ROBERTS:
Exactly, not at all.
WILL PACKER: And so, you
were referencing the pilot,
in our pilot episode, it's
something as simple-- first
of all, the Mitch character
played by Mark-Paul Gosselaar
is somebody who-- and
we all know somebody
like this-- he has
this never-ending quest
to make everything
right in the world.
And he wants
everything to be fair,
and everybody be treated
fairly, and if he
thinks something is wrong, he's
got to stand up and stand up
for justice.
And he's got this need for
that, he can't turn it off,
and sometimes it's great,
it's always well-intentioned,
and sometimes it ends horribly.
And in the pilot episode, as
simple as the guys coming out
of a restaurant and they ask
for their car from vallet-- now
Russell, the black
guy, has driven--
and it's a nice
Porsche that pulls up
and the valet immediately
gives the keys to Mitch.
And Mitch goes, why did
you give the keys to me?
I know why you did.
You did because you didn't think
that this black guy was driving
this fancy car and I
have a problem with that,
I'm going to stand up for it.
And Russell's going, dude,
it's not that serious.
It's a valet stand,
it's not Selma,
let's just go and
get in the car.
And literally, Mitch
will not let it go
and the valet guy
says, no I actually
didn't give you
the keys because I
didn't think the black
guy could drive the car,
I gave you keys because
there's a John Mayer CD
playing in the car.
And Mitch goes, you're
absolutely right,
that was my CD and this is
his car but you're right.
He, either way, whether
it was because he thought
he had some preconceived
notion about the type of car
that a black dude would
drive or the type of music
that a black guy
might listen to,
there is a little bit of
an unconscious bias there,
and it affects us
in everything we do.
Race is just a part of us,
just a part of us as humans
and the way we relate and
interact with each other.
So this is a good opportunity
to bring some levity to it.
Obviously, there have been
some really, really heavy
and serious
situations around race
that have happened very
recently in our country
and around the world.
But I think that if
you can talk about it
and bring some levity to
it-- the important thing
is that the conversation
is happening.
So when you tell
me that Google's
having those conversations
about unconscious bias,
I applaud that tremendously
because the first key is
talking about it.
If we're not talking about
it, if it's something
we're pretending like
it doesn't exist,
and we're sweeping
it under the rug,
all we're doing is
fostering things that
ultimately could be negative.
MARJAI ROBERTS:
Definitely agree.
And--
WILL PACKER: That
was a good answer,
we should stop right now
because that's the best I got,
it's downhill from here,
guys, just going to tell you.
MARJAI ROBERTS: I
definitely agree.
That's one thing
I loved, that it
makes the show a lot more
accessible when you can talk
about these uncomfortable
topics in a way that
brings some humor into it.
And it makes just
more comfortable
in starting the dialogue, so
definitely thank you for that.
So Tone Bell, he is a stand-up
comedian in real life, also
an actor, so was that part of
his character Russell's role
or did you guys add that
in when you cast Tone?
WILL PACKER: No.
What's interesting is that
the character was already
written as a stand-up.
And so Tone Bell, the actor
that plays Russell brilliantly,
is also a stand-up, that made
him fit the role perfectly.
There wasn't a
lot that we needed
to do to shape a role around the
actor, which you do sometimes,
because in this
instance the actor
really, really fit the role.
He really has a lot of
the-- he's a loose guy,
he's a liberal guy,
he's a fun loving guy,
and he happens to be a stand-up.
And him being a stand-up,
and being on the road,
and having to interact
with different audiences
and make them laugh, it
affects his world view.
And so that's in real
life tone, and that's also
the character, Russell.
The thing I'll say
about this cast
is that each of the
characters, they
hadn't worked together before.
Tone Bell and Bresha Webb,
who do play a married couple,
knew each other, they did have
a camaraderie prior to the show.
But there is an organic,
authentic camaraderie
and chemistry amongst
these four that you can
see when you watch the show.
And literally, it's
not just about--
and I've been
fortunate to produce
a lot of content--
and oftentimes,
when you yell "Cut," that's it.
These actors-- I
don't care if they're
playing husband and wife, if
they're in an intimate bedroom
scene-- "Cut."
Get away from me, all right?
Where is my coffee? my latte?
I don't want to talk to you
until it's time to roll.
These actors actually,
genuinely are a family.
They're tight-knit, and they
really, really genuinely
get along, and they
have a great chemistry,
and they hang
outside of the set.
And I bring that up
because these days
authentic content is really what
is resonating with audiences.
Things that feel real-- whether
it's a world, or a character,
or a perspective that
you can relate to,
directly or not-- if it feels
like it's really authentic,
if it feels like it's something
that's very natural and not
manufactured by some Hollywood
writer, producer, or director,
audiences resonate towards that.
They're attracted to
that kind of content.
And so it's really
good that we've
got a foursome that is
actually oragnically--
has great chemistry.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Definitely.
So speaking of
chemistry and everything
that happens on the set, do
you have any funny bloopers
or anything that's happened
on the set since you started?
WILL PACKER: There's a story
that I wouldn't otherwise tell,
but I'll tell it because
she has told it herself.
When Vanessa Lachey, who
is a completely elegant
and classy woman--
MARJAI ROBERTS: Disclaimer.
WILL PACKER: Yes, absolutely--
she stepped away from the set
and started doing what she
calls, "the fart dance."
And she literally
starts doing this dance
and-- the name is apropos--
she is away and thinks
nobody is watching because
she's trying to, I don't know,
scoot it out.
What she didn't know is that
the entire cast and crew are now
stopped and watching her do
her fart dance over there.
And so now she has
to explain what it is
and what she was doing.
And that's how it
came out, and that's
how we knew what she was doing.
I can't think of much
more embarrassing
then being caught
passing gas in front
of a whole crew full of people.
MARJAI ROBERTS: I think that
takes the cake for sure.
Definitely.
So I love Mitch.
You were mentioning
Mark-Paul Gosselaar--
WILL PACKER: Oh
yeah, he's awesome.
MARJAI ROBERTS: He played Zack
Morris on "Saved by the Bell,"
if you guys remember.
WILL PACKER: Yes
he did, yes, yes.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Favorite.
So as you were
mentioning, he reminds you
of that socially conscious
guy that everyone
knows, or is friends with,
that really wants to make sure
that they're instilling,
or projecting,
fairness and justice around
them and everyone around them.
Where do you think Mitch
gets this heightened sense
of consciousness
from or justice from?
WILL PACKER: Well, two things.
Number one, the character of
Mitch is an ethics professor
and so he spends a lot of time
talking about, and studying,
ethics and morality,
and studying
the difference between right
and wrong, the black, and white,
and the gray areas.
It also is based on our
creator, DJ Nash's, actual life
and he is somebody
that's like that.
He likes to say that,
out of this foursome,
the fifth character on the
show is Mitch's white guilt.
And that is very appropriate
for our creator, DJ Nash,
because he is-- in a great, fun,
and lovable way-- somebody that
always wants to make sure that
he's not part of the problem
and that he's
doing everything he
can be a part of the solution,
whatever that may be.
So he instills that in the
writing of our Mitch character,
and it's really fun to have that
kind of guy opposite somebody
like Russell, who has fun
pushing his white guilt buttons
every chance that he gets.
MARJAI ROBERTS: I agree.
There's a scene
where they listen to,
I think, a Jay-Z
song in the car,
and there's a "n"
word that comes up
and the what happens with
that, so that was really funny.
WILL PACKER: It's
good, it's great.
It's "Empire State
of Mind" by Jay-Z,
who was kind enough to
license the song to us,
really appreciate that.
And Mitch-- they're heading
to a Jay-Z concert and Mitch
is so proud that he has
learned all the words
to the Jay-Z verse of
"Empire Sate of Mind."
He is like, oh my god,
you've got to hear me do it.
And he's rapping it,
and of course, Jay-Z
drops the "n" word every
other verse, and so
when he gets to the "n"
word, and he's so ready
to say it, that's when
Russell steps in, cuts off,
no, no, no, no, no.
What are you doing?
No, you don't do that.
And Mitch is, but I learned it,
but you should hear me say it.
I don't pronounce the "-er,"
I do it like Jay-Z, let me.
And he's like, no you can't.
So in the episode,
he then forces
Mitch to only sing the
Alicia Keys' part, which
turns out much more disastrous.
MARJAI ROBERTS:
Yeah, it's not good.
Definitely.
So we hear a lot of dialogue in
the news and in our community
that diversity and actors,
and seeing people, diversity,
on TV, is really important
in our community today.
And I think we
forget a lot of times
that the people in the
background, it's just
is important for them to be
diverse as well because they
are the decision makers.
So how does that impact you?
Do you agree or do
you think that's fair
that it's really important to
have that diversity in sitting
at the table?
WILL PACKER: Yeah.
First of all, diversity
is important for a couple
of reasons.
Not only because
it's the right thing
to do, just to be upfront
and blatant about it,
but also because it makes
good business sense.
That's what America
looks like now.
It does not look like
just one monolithic group,
America looks like how
the world looks, diverse.
And various races, ethnicities,
and cultural backgrounds,
and sexual orientations.
So if you're going
to make content
for the broadest
possible audience,
you need to represent
that audience.
So that's something
that's very important.
When you talk about behind the
scenes, people like myself,
you're right.
Obviously, I'm going to have a
different level of sensitivity
about diversity, perhaps, than
some of my white counterparts.
Doesn't mean that we both
can't push it in the same way,
but it is important to
have diversity in front,
and behind, the camera
because it informs
the decisions that you make.
And so in order to have great
shows that are organically
diverse-- again, not just,
let's cast a person of color
because we need to
meet some quota,
but actual themes
and subject matters
that are organic to
a diverse cast-- then
you have to have people
that really understand
and have a perspective.
It also makes the
content better.
Because if you and I like
something, it could be good,
but I don't know, you've only
got some very small sample.
But if this entire
room likes it,
the chances of it being
good are even better.
And so the more
diverse voices that you
have weighing in on the type
of content that you're making,
the better chance you have
of that content being better.
MARJAI ROBERTS:
Definitely agree.
WILL PACKER: That was my
second best answer, guys.
Do you want to cut it--
MARJAI ROBERTS: Clap
for that one too.
WILL PACKER: Should
we keep going?
Look, boom man in the
back is like, yeah bro,
you're downhill from here.
I'm with you.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Definitiely.
So movies, TV, what are
some of the similarities
and differences for you and
producing on both sides?
WILL PACKER: It's all
about creating content.
The process is different,
very different actually,
in terms of creating in
the different mediums,
but at the end of the day,
it's about character stories,
richness, doing it
well in a quality way,
and finding an audience for it.
That's really what it's about.
So whether it's the big
screen, for the small screen,
for the digital medium,
it doesn't really matter.
For me, it's about what are the
stories we're trying to tell,
what are the characters
we're trying to create,
and who wants to see those
characters, who will relate,
or who will be attracted
to those characters
in those stores.
That's really the key for me.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Definitely.
So you're based
in Atlanta and you
started a lot of
your productions
in Atlanta, which has
become one of the fastest
growing production
hubs in the US
with all the tax incentives
in the state, what is it
like producing in Atlanta?
And how do you like it?
WILL PACKER: Atlanta's great.
It's obviously-- we're
here at a global company
and the world now is
completely connected.
And so no matter where
you produce the content--
ultimately,
distribution has changed
and no matter where you
are, where it's produced,
you can get access to content.
So a lot of times, the decisions
about where to make the content
are driven by creative
and by fiscal.
So ultimately, Atlanta's a great
market that's been very smart,
the state of Georgia has put
text incentives in place.
It was my home market
market even before those tax
incentives were in
place, I like it
because it has a lot
of different looks,
so as a creative
person you can shoot
something that can be very
metropolitan, also very rural.
It's Southern, but yet because
it has so many transplants,
it has a flavor that feels very
diverse, not just Southern.
So I like it for
personal reasons
because I like that
kind of diversity
and I like that kind of cultural
melting pot that Atlanta is.
But for business
reasons, it is now
at the forefront of one of the
most efficient places to shoot,
and other studios and
producers are following suit.
And that's how it works
in my business, where
the tax incentives are-- you
build it, they will come.
You put a tax incentive
in place, whoever's
got the highest percentage, you
will find your favorite shows
and movies, and other content--
documentaries, whatever it is--
being shot in those markets.
MARJAI ROBERTS: I heard
in a BET Genius Talks
interview you did with
Boris Kodjoe last year,
you mentioned that if newcomers
want Hollywood to pay attention
to them, they really have to
start making their own content
and starting to make
money on that content.
That reminded me a lot
of our YouTube creators
and how they're using
limited resources to build up
a subscribership and fan base.
So how big do you
think technology
has played in helping creators
get their work out there?
And how different was that for
you when you first started?
WILL PACKER: Technology's huge.
Technology, it affects
everything that we do,
but you can't overstate
the impact of technology
on the film and
television business.
So in every aspect
at every level--
I don't care if you're
talking about a $150 million
tent pole production or a
$2 million indie-- the way
that that content is created now
is affected by the technology
level that we're at right now.
So for me, I love it
because what it has done
is remove some of the
barriers that were there
for young artists who want to
get into the movie business.
Because now, when
I first started
I had to shoot my
first film, on film.
I had to go out and actually
buy celluloid to shoot my film,
60 millimeters is what
we shot it on-- Super 16,
actually, thank you very
much-- and we shot the film,
and we had to edit
it, and we didn't
have digital capabilities
at that time.
Now, you can shoot a
movie, a complete movie,
on your cell phone, on your
smartphone, absolutely.
So on your Android
smartphone, by the way.
I love that because
now you can go out
and you don't have to go to
one of the gatekeepers to say,
will you give me
a ton of resources
in order to create my content.
And if it's good enough, and
if people want to see it,
and they will go and follow
you on YouTube and click it,
and you have a bunch of views,
Hollywood will pay attention.
Hollywood, by its very nature,
is a reactive industry.
It's not very proactive,
unfortunately.
It's reactive.
And so you have an opportunity
to get Hollywood's attention
because those
barriers aren't there.
You can go out with
very limited resources,
and if you're good,
if you're creative,
if you how to market it, you
know how to find an audience,
Hollywood will find you and
say, help us to exploit you.
It's what they will do.
But ultimately, it
gets your content out
to a wider audience.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Definitely.
So you already gave
us a little bit
of advice for
budding producers, do
you have any other
words of encouragement
for content creators
and producers
out there trying to get their--
WILL PACKER: Go out and do it.
Go out-- and that's
my thing now, go out.
Don't use the excuse
of, well, I haven't
gotten to a particular
level, I don't
have enough resources--
go out and do it.
Inevitabily, the more you
do, the better you will get.
And so what I always tell young
people interested in getting
into the business is don't
wait for somebody like me,
or anybody else, to come
and ordain you, and give you
a shot, and say, here's
a big Hollywood budget.
Just go out and do it.
Go out and start shooting.
Your first stuff is
probably going to be bad.
That's OK, get that
out of your system
and get to the good stuff.
I think that because people
that are really ambitious
and go getters, and
really passionate
and driven about it, now because
there are so many avenues
to be able to create
your own stuff--
and in distribution outlets,
there are more cable,
and on demand outlets,
and digital outlets,
and channels online to put your
content on and have it seen
by a wide audience than there
ever were before-- so if you're
hungry and you're really
serious about doing,
there is an opportunity there.
So now that the
excuses are removed,
you have a lot more people
that are creating content,
so now the cream has
to rise to the top.
You have to figure out how to
make your content good enough
that people will notice
it because there's
a lot of content out there.
So now it challenges you as
a filmmaker, as an actor,
as a writer, as a director,
to stand out and be better
than some of the peers out there
that are just throwing stuff
at the wall.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Definitely.
So we're going to start taking
a few audience questions,
so you can definitely go and
line up in the middle there.
But before that, I
wanted to ask you
what inspired you to
get into filmmaking?
I know some of you
may not know that you
graduated from FAMU with an
electrical engineering degree--
WILL PACKER: I did, yes.
MARJAI ROBERTS: --so that
resonates here at Google.
But how did you leap from
engineering to film ?
WILL PACKER: I never had a
passion for engineering--
no offense to present
company-- but for me, I
was strong in technology,
and math, and science
coming in to college and I got
a scholarship to pursue that.
And there was a
push at that time,
not unsimilar to how it is now,
to increase minority graduates
in technical fields.
And so I got a scholarship
that encouraged me to go into
to get a degree in electrical
engineering, and along the way,
I hooked up with a buddy,
a lifelong friend of mine
named Rob Hardy, and he wanted
to be a director, that's
all he wanted to do.
He was like, I want to
be a movie director.
That wasn't my
particular passion,
but I wanted to be
an entrepreneur.
And so I helped him to
make his first movie.
And after we made it, I was able
to get distribution, hustle it
into the theaters locally.
Ultimately, I helped him
get the actor, the finance
and the distribution,
and then do that again
with another small project.
And later I learned that's
what a producer basically
does, you go and get financing
for projects and create it.
So I stumbled into
being a movie producer,
it wasn't something
that I checked a box
when you're trying
to figure out what
your career's going to be as
a teenager or college student.
But we were able to
make it successful,
we took a little small movie
and made a little bit of money,
and I said, you know what?
This is my entrepreneurial
endeavor right here,
this is a business model.
I'm going to go and I'm going
to do this movie producer thing.
I learned on the job, never went
to film school, trial by fire,
making a lot of
mistakes, doing a lot
of things wrong, but
ultimately hustled until I
got to the point where
my content actually was
good enough for people to see.
And a lot of people to
see it, at this point.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Definitely.
Congratulations on that success.
WILL PACKER: Thank you.
MARJAI ROBERTS: So what are
you most proud of of "Truth Be
Told?"
And I would love to learn
more about any future projects
you're working on now.
WILL PACKER: With "Truth Be
Told," I'm proud of the fact
that its organically
diverse, it's
not something that
is a show that's
diverse for diverse's sake.
It's a show about real people,
and it pushes the envelope,
it's provocative but
not in an offensive way.
It's fun, it's light
and I like that.
And I think that the timing
is right for that kind of show
on television and I
think that audiences
who tune in and watch it, will
fall in love these characters.
I'm proud of that, I'm
proud to be a part of it.
MARJAI ROBERTS:
Definitely, congrats.
So we'll take a few
Q&A from the audience.
AUDIENCE: First, I would
like to say, welcome Rattler.
WILL PACKER: Oh!
Thank you.
FAMU in the house.
AUDIENCE: Also an EE.
WILL PACKER: Love that.
AUDIENCE: Probably the
same scholarship program
and also not an
engineer anymore.
WILL PACKER: I love it,
when did you come out?
AUDIENCE: I came out in
2000, so my contemporaries
would be people like John
Brown, Joe Carrol-- I
was on Senate with him-- Reggie
Harris and that whole crew.
WILL PACKER: Absolutely.
Wow, what a small world.
MARJAI ROBERTS: That's
actually a manager on my team.
WILL PACKER: Really?
I love it.
AUDIENCE: So I've been
watch you work ever since--
WILL PACKER: We should just
keep the "convo" between us,
this is--
AUDIENCE: Right, exactly.
WILL PACKER: --completely
irreverent to everybody
in the room, and
everybody has no idea
what we're talking about,
but that's awesome.
AUDIENCE: That'll be lunch.
WILL PACKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I've been watching
your work since Chocolate City
at TOPS, Trois.
Interested in-- I know the
journey that you've gone
through and I've been watching
for probably, what is it now--
WILL PACKER: Chocolate
City was my first movie,
I know that you might
be a little lost.
When I was a student
at FAMU, Florida A&M,
I did a little small, small,
movie, that $20,000 movie,
and it's called Chocolate City.
It was a movie about
college life as we knew it.
Horrible little movie but it
started a pretty nice career.
All right, where were we?
AUDIENCE: And we all had
to watch in orientation.
So on this journey,
I know there's
a lot of personal development
behind the success
that people see outwardly,
I'm interested in knowing
what is probably some of the
biggest personal challenges
that you've had to
grow through in order
to be able to look at the
Will Packer that was then,
to the person that
we see now before us?
WILL PACKER: That's
an excellent question.
For me, my personal
growth has all
been around learning the
work-life balance because when
I get the opportunity to come
and have talks like this,
and talk to people, it is
always about the success
that I've had as a film
producer or television producer,
and the projects that I
have and what's coming up.
But what really, really
defines me is family
because if you ask
me who I am, I'm
going to say I'm a father and a
husband first who also happens
to work in Hollywood.
So for me, that balance--
my foundation is very strong
and allows me to go out
and do the work that I
do in a very, very
challenging, competitive field
because I've got that
great family foundation.
And so as I have
grown personally,
the maturity to really
understand and grasp
that work-life balance
has been immense in terms
of giving me a leg up,
even on some of my peers
who don't have that.
AUDIENCE: First, thank you for
spending some time with us,
know you're very busy--
WILL PACKER: I thought you're
going to say you were from FAMU
and I was going to
say, this is a setup,
this whole room is fake.
None of you people work
at Google, what is this?
Is this an intervention?
What's going on?
No.
AUDIENCE: Not quite.
But I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about what
pressure, if any you feel, as
one of a handful of producers
that can push content through
the Hollywood machine featuring
predominantly African-American
actors or themes.
I know the two aren't
always the same,
but what pressure,
if any, you feel?
I wonder if you could
talk about that?
WILL PACKER: First of
all, when you say handful,
it's a small hand, I'm
going to be honest with you.
There are not many
African-American producers
that are fortunate enough
to produce on the level
that I have been fortunate
enough to produce on.
I see it as an opportunity
because right now I
am one of very few
voices, so I always
want to be the
person-- the parable is
the shoe salesman who goes
into the land of no shoes.
It's-- I don't know,
people look at me crazy.
So this story is that there
were two shoe salesmen,
and one went to
this far away town
and came back to the
shoe company and said,
oh this is horrible, we
can go into this town.
They don't know what a shoe is,
they don't wear shoes, move on.
And then the second salesman
went to the same town
and came back and said, oh
my god, this is perfect.
Unlimited potential for growth.
We can take it over and start
our whole marketing machine
here, and so he saw
an opportunity there.
So for me, I see an
opportunity if I'm
the only one in the
room that's doing
a particular type of content.
But I know that's
going to change,
and I know that if
I do it well, it
would open the door--
because, as I said earlier,
Hollywood is reactive--
and so you will have people
that will say, give me more of
insert successful content here.
Give me more movies and
TV shows like insert
successful producers'
content there.
So for me I see it as a
responsibility, but also
an opportunity.
And I know it will
change, it will.
Right now I'm definitely
enjoying the ride
because it allows
me to take risks
because the expectations
are still not
extremely high for
content that is diverse.
It's changing though, it's
changing because you look
at the top shows on television
and the top movies in theaters
for the last-- there
was a run of five weeks,
it started with "Straight Outta
Compton," where the number one
movie in the country featured
African-American leads for five
weeks in a row.
And then, of course, the number
one show on television right
now is "Empire," so
it says something
about the-- and those aren't
just black audiences that
are watching those shows-- so
it says something about where
the country is in terms
of the type of content
they're willing to embrace.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Thanks guys.
So one question I did
want to ask about,
that I'm excited about,
is you are producing
the remake of "Roots" and
I'm hearing about "Uncle
Buck," which was a remake.
Mike Epps is playing
it, originally--
WILL PACKER: John Candy.
MARJAI ROBERTS: --John Candy.
So I'm excited about those,
can you tell us a little bit,
sneak peak about that or--
WILL PACKER: Sure, yeah.
Two very different
projects, obviously,
"Uncle Buck" and "Roots."
So I don't see a mash
up coming any time soon.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Not at all.
WILL PACKER: "Uncle Buck"
is an interesting project
because it is revered
in a lot of circles.
The great John Candy,
it's a cult classic,
nobody will ever be John Candy
and we didn't approach it
with an eye towards
replacing John Candy
or doing the same show, the
same movie, as a TV show.
We looked at the theme, the
heart of what that was about,
and we made it our own.
And so we've got an
amazing team of creators
that have put a show together
around the super talented
comedian, Mike Epps, and it
follows that same formula
that was in "Uncle Buck," but
it's a very different show.
And it's something I'm
excited about because I think
it's a type of show that will
resonate with audiences today
because it's real.
Families today are not just
the traditional families
of '80s television, they
look a lot different,
and this is a family that
looks a lot different.
And then with "Roots,"
that is something that I'm
really, really proud of.
I'm proud to be a part of it.
It's obviously a
tremendous undertaking
that I don't take
lightly, remaking
an iconic classic, the
most watched television
series in television history.
It is something that
I'm doing because I
know there's an entire
generation of youth that
have not seen it and it deserves
a contemporary retelling.
So we've got an amazing
team, amazing actors,
amazing directors and I'm
happy to be a part of it.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Great,
we're looking forward to it.
So at this point, I wanted
to play rapid fire with you.
We do this sometimes
on Talks at Google.
So I'm going to throw a few one
or the other questions at you
and pick the first one.
WILL PACKER: This is where
it goes off the rails.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Here
we go, here we go--
WILL PACKER: Heavy
editing in this part
of the show people, all right.
MARJAI ROBERTS:
So LA or New York?
WILL PACKER: For what?
I don't-- see,
that's why I'm bad,
I'm already messing
up with this.
Because immediately
different things came.
To visit, to work, to--
MARJAI ROBERTS: Anything.
WILL PACKER: --run from the law?
Which-- what are we?
I'm going to go LA.
MARJAI ROBERTS: LA.
OK.
Truth or dare?
WILL PACKER: Dare.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Early
riser or night owl?
WILL PACKER: Night owl.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Since you live
in Georgia, UGA or Georgia
Tech?
Careful.
WILL PACKER: U-- UGA.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Yes.
Good answer, good answer.
Go dogs!
Spring or Fall?
WILL PACKER: Spring.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Good.
Salty or sweet?
WILL PACKER: A little of both.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Good.
"Martin" or "Fresh Prince?"
WILL PACKER: Oh my god, Martin.
Martin.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Coffee or tea?
WILL PACKER: Tea.
MARJAI ROBERTS: SWV or TLC?
WILL PACKER: Oh wow TLC.
MARJAI ROBERTS: OK,
there we go, well done.
WILL PACKER: Woo!
All right.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Thank
you so much, Will,
for coming to Google.
WILL PACKER: Thank you for
having me, this was awesome.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Yeah,
thanks for taking time out
of your busy schedule
to visist us.
WILL PACKER: Thank you, Google.
Can we talk about
my search engine?
I'd love it so that
when you just look up
pretty much anything,
myself pops up.
I don't who we--
MARJAI ROBERTS: It's
supposed to work out--
WILL PACKER: --if somebody
in this room can-- Or when--
MARJAI ROBERTS: I'll
talk to a technician.
WILL PACKER: --you Google
me, Denzel and Edris--
50% of the time-- their
photos pop up next to mine.
Can we-- I don't know--
MARJAI ROBERTS: I'll
set up a meeting--
WILL PACKER: That's not a yes.
I'd like, while we're on
camera, to get you to say--
MARJAI ROBERTS: It's a yes.
WILL PACKER: I'll talk to
somebody, don't worry about it,
I'll wander around these halls.
Security is tight
here, by the way.
We have to have an amazing
guide, Dana, who's here,
I've got to give
her a shout out.
I tried to go to the
bathroom without Dana
and it didn't work out so well.
Dana was like, you
don't want to do that.
I was like, it's
Google, like what?
She was like, you
don't want to do that.
So I didn't do it, I'm
going to listen to Dana,
y'all are serious around here.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Very cool.
So I did want to mention Viola
Davis, during her historic Emmy
win last month--
WILL PACKER: Yes, I was
there, there in person.
So awesome to see.
MARJAI ROBERTS: That amazing.
She made a comment that
the only thing that
separates woman of color from
anyone else is opportunity,
and she went on to thank
a lot of the producers
and writers in her life that
have made that opportunity
available to her.
So I wanted to take
the time to thank you
for doing that as well
and creating opportunity
to everyone in the
entertainment industry--
WILL PACKER: Thank
you for saying that.
MARJAI ROBERTS: --so, thank you.
WILL PACKER:
Absolutely, thank you.
MARJAI ROBERTS: Thank you
WILL PACKER: Thank you so much.
Thank you everybody.
Awesome.
Great job.
My, my.
[MUSIC PLAYING]